at the end of my video on misconceptions
I mentioned the supposed fact that
people swallow ate spiders a year while
sleeping but unlike the other
misconceptions in that video which I
explained away I turned this one into a
cheap joke and left it at that this
wasn't because it's true but because the
story behind that myth turns out to be a
bit of a mystery the first place I
remember coming across the eight spiders
fact was years ago on the lid of a
Snapple can Snapple used to print facts
of dubious value on their drinks and
though they've tried to hide it the
Wayback Machine reveals that eight
spiders was one of them take a trip to
snopes.com the go-to site for debunking
urban legends of all kinds and sure
enough the eight spiders a year thing is
listed scroll down and snoop says the
story came from Lisa Holtz in 1993 when
email is still fairly new for most
people and messages with subjects like
re re forward are eerie forward amazing
facts were a higher proportion of
network traffic
Lisa host says Snopes word an article
called reading is believing in PC
professional listing all kinds of
made-up facts that people would believe
and eight spiders a year was one of them
this I thought was the perfect
misconception to finish the video like a
little moral on why you should be less
credulous out of interest I went looking
for the article to see what other fake
facts she mentioned but googling for her
brought up nothing well not literally
nothing but nothing helpful mostly these
other articles debunking the eight
spiders myth using the exact same
language as the Snopes article which
looks suspicious intrigued I contacted
Snopes myself about their source but got
back a forum reply I don't know if
ignoring their contact form is their
usual way of doing business
along with copy/paste blocking and
pop-under ads but it seemed odd for a
site dedicated to exposing the truth for
the digging yielded other articles about
people like myself trying to find Lisa
Halston verify Snopes his version of the
story there's a page on meta filter and
Stack Exchange and even a website called
eight spiders com that went looking for
her the guy who runs that last one even
went so far as to contact the Library of
Congress who said they didn't know of
any magazine called PC professional
which leaves us in an odd xkcd kind of
mood about Snopes if the Lisa host
version of the story is real then why
can't anyone find any record of her or
her article and if it's not real is it
just a mistake on Snopes his part if so
why haven't they replied to any of the
people who brought it to their attention
or perhaps we've gone through the
looking glass and the Lisa holes made up
the eight spiders a year fact is the
myth promulgated by none other than
Snopes themselves it wouldn't be the
first time as Snopes does have a
purposely fake article on the site
claiming that mr. ed was actually a
zebra I wasn't able to go any further
than this but if you happen to know
anything about Lisa host or the deal
with Snopes please feel free to get in
touch or leave a video response